breaking news wollen direkt ins
luschniki stadion in moskau schauen denn
gleich wird der russische präsident
wladimir putin sprechen wir haben es
eben schon von unserem korrespondenten
peter thiele gehört es wird erwartet
dass er dort die einnahme der stadt
mario pohl verkünden wird und dass
eventuell auch mit dem einsatz von
atomwaffen drohen wird wir sind also
sehr gespannt was der russische
präsident dort gleich sagen wird das
ganze ja eine ziemlich große propaganda
veranstaltung heute nämlich ist der
achte jahrestag zur annexion der krim
und wir haben schon bilder gesehene von
kindern die da ebene zu einem mit z
sozusagen zusammen formatiert wurden die
dieses z raushalten mussten also dieses
creek symbol und jetzt wollen wir mal
direkt rein schauen eben ins
luschniki-stadion hier sehen wir jetzt
noch einen russischen reporter
zugeschaltet der diese veranstaltung
dort kommentiert ja und im hintergrund
sehen wir wehende fahnen russland fahren
also putin claqueure die dort in dieses
stadion eingeladen wurden um den
präsidenten zuzujubeln paul ronzheimer
zugeschaltet aus kiew was ist von dieser
veranstaltung heute zu erwarten paul und
vor allem auch von der rede putins
[Musik]
ja ich glaube das was von putin zu
erwarten ist das sind zynische lügen die
er seit wochen verbreitet und hier der
ort an dem ich gerade stehe der beweist
erneut wie putin vorgeht das sind
wohngebiete all das hier ist ein
wohngebiet ich zeige euch das mal schaut
euch an was hier passiert ist ein
angriff am morgen von der russischen
armee das sind beweise das zeigt wie
hier weiterhin zivile ziele angegriffen
werden und wie wladimir putin finnische
lügen dass das ein militär ziel sein
soll in sich zusammenfallen was hat sich
nur wann das auch russland begreift ich
nehme dich einfach mal oder nimmt die
zuschauer hier weiter mit durch dieses
schlachtfeld so muss man es nennen
schaut euch diese zerstörung angerichtet
mit russischen waffen und wir gehen hier
wir werden jetzt einmal weg geschickt
denn einmal in die richtung
wir haben die richtung hier weiter rein
schaut euch auch diese zerstörung an
hier das haus ist das ist es was die
bittere realität ist von putins krieg
denn nach foul am wahnsinnig skurril die
bilder die uns da aus dem
luschniki-stadion erreichen claqueure
fahnen russische fahnen die da wären die
einen präsidenten zu jubeln die menschen
wissen offensichtlich nicht was bei dir
passiert was in der ukraine passiert
ja oder sie wollen es nicht wissen sie
wollen nicht wahrnehmen dass das hier
zivile wohnhäuser sind sie angegriffen
wurden dass das da hinten autos sind die
komplett zerstört wurden hier das muss
man sich vorstellen hier hinter mir
sieht man ein spielplatz ja das hier war
ein spielplatz wo kinder tagsüber
spielen ich bin können nur hoffen dass
die meisten menschen so zu sagen hier
schon raus sind aber wenn wir hier
weiter gehen und sehen was in diesen
häusern passiert ist dann muss man
einfach feststellen
das ist die totale zerstörungswut auch
der russischen armee gegen zivile ziele
das sind wirklich der unfassbare bilder
paul die du uns da zeigte dieser angriff
dann hat er genau stattgefunden
am frühen morgen hat diese angriff
stattgefunden wir wissen von einem toten
zum glück nur einer muss man sagen
angesichts des ausmaßes der zerstörung
19 verletzte soll es gegeben haben vier
kinder hier ganz in der nähe dort weiter
in diese richtung
ist auch eine schule untergebracht man
sieht dass hier schon aufräumarbeiten
stattfinden offenbar sucht man hier nach
der nach der rakete ich versuche ich
nochmal weiterzukommen in diese richtung
jorgos und
wir sehen wenn wir in die richtung film
nochmal weiter gehen hier soll gut wenn
wir in diese richtung gehen
das war mal ein auto hier das muss man
sich mal vorstellen was hier passiert in
diesem land sieht aus wie ein
schrottplatz aber es war ein
raketenangriff und wir sehen wenn wir
auf dieses wenn wir auf dieses haus
filmen dort um sehen wir was hier
angerichtet wurde welche blinde
zerstörungswut
der russischen armee habe da die
mögliche ein unfassbar zurücklassen paul
das ist wirklich nicht zu glauben was da
bei dir passiert diese tatsächlichen
angriffe mitten in wohngebiete auf
schulen auf theater auf häuser und ich
zeig dir
ich zeig dir einmal wo die schule ist
wir müssen hier einmal durch dieses
verstörte das ist ein fahrrad was man
ein fahrrad war und wenn wir hier weiter
gehen hier ein radio
und das
ist mal ein auto gewesen wird dort stand
unfassbar sie sehen ich will euch zeigen
wo hier eine schule war ja wir sehen ja
auch spielgeräte da paul die ganze zeit
an der seite das scheint auch irgendwo
einen spielplatz gewesen zu sein obwohl
man das kaum noch erkennen kann
tatsächlich nur vereinzelte kleinere
teile die darauf hindeuten noch
absolut und dort weiter in der ecke in
diese richtung so zu sagen da war eine
schule untergebracht die auch teilweise
zerstört worden ist und die kinder
laut witali klitschko der heute morgen
auch hier war in mindestens vier kinder
bei diesem angriff verletzt worden und
wenn wir auf vladimir putin schauen und
auf seine rede die er gleich folgen soll
dann ist das sein werk schillig
[Applaus]